hello I'm Tess Lidge and tonight we're
going to learn about the mother of
Halloween mrs. Elizabeth Chris in the
early decades of the 20th century
Halloween was celebrated in a far
different way
this was 1912 in Hiawatha Kansas and
groups of kids would gather together
where a mass and they would just like
destroy and they're like oh shoot
an outhouse what are we gonna do that
out us tip it the hell over you that
that's right
and then they would set it on fire and
then they laughs and then before you
know it the entire town is just like
turned over outhouses beheaded chickens
babies punched in the head the kids the
hooligans are like I'm a boy with the
penis and peeing in the hole devil's
name
that's scary it's terrible it's just
like it's just terrible so on the
morning of November 1st 1912 day after
Halloween obviously Elizabeth Krebs
founder of the Hiawatha Garden Club
wakes up parts the curtains and saw her
car
was completely that and she's like this
is insane but the heirloom roses before
the Astor's the like gourds and she's
like what's wrong with these kids what
do they need you know what I think they
need is a party burn off that demoness
energy is that a word yeah
anyway listen October 31st 1913
Elizabeth Krabs is like whenever I'm
gonna have a decent-sized party not a
big party Who am I the king of rum no so
she does it and the neighborhood kids
come through like a pretty cool party
mrs. Krebbs bobbing for apples like a
movie pew bobbing for apples and then it
just keeps going like ad nauseam on
repeat until the end of the evening so
Elizabeth Krabs is like I have a feeling
this is really gonna work I've exhausted
this youthful population to the point
where they can't do this is awesome
so she goes to bed wakes up the next
morning November 1st 1913 parts the
curtains but everything is leveled again
and Elizabeth Krebs is like no are
you kidding me and look at that a mail
trucks on fire someone's waiting for a
postcard that's never gonna arrive
because then mail truck out with a bun
fire and she's like I had this
decent-sized party how could these kids
even have it in them to take a piss on
everything but then Elizabeth Krabs is
like you know what I got an idea so she
goes home and Elizabeth Crabb spends the
entire next year planning for this party
and she devoted all of her own time and
resources and money into making a huge
rager
nice built I'll be all that way and now
look for the hold of it I dribbled and I
dribbled so it is October 31st 1914
she's waiting a town square and
eventually what's that kids in costumes
trickling in to the town square
ready to rage and she's like thank God
because I knew this was gonna be a thing
and it was so these kids these hooligans
are at this party and ban comes in
starts playing that's fell weak sauce
weak sauce I love that soon so anyway
the hooligans are like timid
I'm pretty shocked that old mrs. Krabs
thrown like the coolest party I ever
seen in Hiawatha Kansas and so everybody
gets marched down to the Armstrong Opera
House and Elizabeth Krabs is like yo
that's a long way and those kids are
gonna be tired by the time they get
there and they're actually really
enjoying themselves and they're like man
this is my jam this is Danny boys top of
the charts so the band keeps playing
playing playing until these kids are
like the zombified it's like thriller
and Elizabeth Krebs is like that's good
I like that
hello yeah so she goes home she goes to
bed wakes up next morning November 1st
1914 what does she see how's her garden
looking Derek I'm not sure I'm a little
worried that it's gonna be destroyed no
she looks out and she's like asters
right there
heirloom roses right there and gourds
bloom it's like all this is lined
up it's exactly as it should be people
are in awe of her they're like Elizabeth
nobody destroyed my house nobody broke
my windows Chief of Police comes up
Thank You Elizabeth Krebs thank you
because guess what vandalism reports way
down precipitously and actually nobody
was up to anything other than partying
in your rager she's like damn straight
and he's like we're gonna keep this
tradition rolling pretty much forever
she's like sounds good so it changed the
way we celebrate Halloween here and
everywhere that was all because one
woman Elizabeth Krebs said Halloween is
not about turning over outhouses
to put poo on people's lawns it is about
dressing up really cute getting a
ton of candy booyah
oh this is real cherish because I
know I do get those oh I think I handled
it at this one no all right it's all
gone Erica
you